David Skelly,Museum Director>>
I've been coming here since I
was about five years old and I
walked through the door down
the hall there and seeing an
animal that size really had a
huge effect on me.
And I know that's
true for many people.
[mid tempo rock music ]♪
There aren't a lot of
organizations that have the
talent and capacity to do this
kind of work. These mounts that
we are taking care of are both
scientifically really valuable
but also
historically important. And so
taking them apart has to be
done really carefully by people
who absolutely know what
to expect. And because RCI has
worked on so many projects like
this they're just total pros
about it.
[mid tempo rock music
with lead guitar ]♪
Matt Fair, Research Casting International>>
Each skeleton
Comes apart slightly different.
There's a lot of similarities
between this and other ones
we've done but every time we
always find something new.
[tapping noise]
Something else is
holding it ...
One of the new things is
everything's plastered
together here. And it doesn't
mean it hasn't happened in the
past but they're really
plastered together. It makes a
little bit more difficult
because you have to be careful
when you separate it off the
steel you try and chip the
plaster and you have to
do it without breaking bones.
David Skelly>> It's not just the size
or the number of the fossils it's the
fact that they also get the
artistry that's involved here
too, because you're having to
think about how you make
something that's been dead for
a hundred and fifty million
years look like it's alive.
[mid tempo rock music ]♪
David Skelly>>This hall will look
quite different when it reopens.
The mounts overall will be
much more lifelike,
they'll represent behavior in a
way that they haven't
in the past. So I think it'll
be a different kind of
experience for visitors.
David Skelly cintinues>>In the big picture
this project is happening because museums
like the Peabody remain
really important.
This is where scientists get
together to tell stories to the
wider world and that's never
been more important than it
is now. That's what it's about.
And so this is a chance for us
to update all of
that and get it right.
[music ends]